my parents would tie us together via a
rope so that we were always together and
i could always make sure she obeyed the
therapist when she heard that story was
just
like really shocked and she looked at me
and she said elizabeth that's child
abuse and i was like
my parents said it was fine like they
thought it was fine and she was like no
that's child abuse you know the
religious group your parents are in is
definitely a cult
[Music]
i am faith elizabeth hunter and today
i'm going to be talking about how i grew
up in a cult there was no tv in our
house we weren't allowed to watch movies
or television shows we weren't allowed
to listen to any
contemporary non-christian music i was
not allowed to cut my hair i was not
allowed to wear makeup i was not allowed
to wear high heels i felt like there
were so many rules i know we had like a
notebook with all the rules listed and
it's kind of weird to think back on that
the cult i was in was part of the
institute in basic life principles which
was started by bill gothard and he ran a
homeschool program called the advanced
training institute we read the bible
every day we were supposed to meditate
and think about the bible i would wake
up at least by 6 am and read the bible
for 30 minutes and then our education
was all driven around the bible so we
had bible lessons throughout the day
whether it was english math science it
was always scripture all of our like
life skills were driven to be married so
i knew that once i was like 17 or 18 it
was time to start thinking about getting
married and i wasn't supposed to date or
flirt with any guys because my dad was
going to pick my husband and then all of
my life skills were all about
things i needed to do to be a good wife
so i learned how to bake bread and i
learned how to sew and i learned how to
play piano so if my husband wanted me to
play piano for the church then i could
play the piano for the church
the biggest idea i remember is that
everything in life is determined by your
dad and there's an umbrella of authority
that your dad has so
there's god your dad and then you so if
you do anything that goes outside of
your dad's instructions then god will no
longer protect you and you could be open
to all sorts of danger my dad told me if
i ever speed like if i ever drive down
the road faster than i'm supposed to
then i'd be out from under the umbrella
of protection and god would let me get
in a car wreck and die because i was not
obeying my dad because i was speeding
and he did not want me to speed so then
for several years after i was got my
driver's license i was terrified anytime
i noticed that i'd gone over the speed
limit that i was gonna die and it was
gonna be my fault because god was going
to let me die
i got sick with like the flu or
something and i remember i was getting
cold medicine and my mom looked at me
and she said so you're sick so you must
have done something to get sick you god
is punishing you because you've gone out
from under the umbrella of protection
and you've gotten like this is why
you're sick as you must have done
something to be punished and i was like
racking my brain trying to think of
something i did to disobey my parents to
be out from under the umbrella of
protection to get sick and i couldn't
think of it and i was really distraught
but of course i was sick so i wasn't
thinking that properly but that was
always a warning that whenever you got
sick or were physically injured of any
way that their first thought was
you must have done something and god let
this happen to you because you disobeyed
when i would go into the grocery store
we weren't allowed to look at the
magazines with like celebrities on them
because that was like immoral and bad
and my dad would encourage us to turn
the magazines over so turn them to the
back while we're standing in line at the
grocery store so that they wouldn't be a
temptation to people coming in line
after us i didn't know who the beatles
were i don't know who anybody was i was
not allowed to wear any clothing that
had words on the front of it because my
mom said it brought attraction to my
bodies my dad didn't like me wearing
green because he didn't like the color
green so my mom told me not to put on
green clothes because it would be
offensive to my dad and i was supposed
to honor my dad i was not allowed to
stay up past 8 30 at night i went to bed
at 8 30 every day
i was not allowed to eat any like
non-kosher food because my dad wanted us
to obey the laws of the old testament my
food was highly regulated by my parents
and like they decided what we did and
didn't eat i was not allowed to read any
books that were not approved by my
parents one book i knew that was not
approved by my parents that i got in
trouble for reading was anne frank the
diary of a young girl someone gave it to
my parents and it was on the bookshelf
and i took it and read it and i got in
trouble for that because it wasn't
approved
i was a child who played with dolls and
then i was an adult and there was no in
between i never had a chance to like go
on a first date and like have that like
first crush because every
crushes were considered bad i didn't get
to like experience messing up on your
makeup dyeing your hair silly color i
didn't get to like actually think
through and decide things for myself i
didn't get to make decisions as a
teenager every decision was made for me
so then i when i was an adult it was i
had crippling anxiety to figure out how
to start making decisions on my own
because my whole life my parents had
made every decision for me
[Music]
so i was being stalked at college by
several different guys in my classes
because i didn't understand how to set
boundaries and i was telling my roommate
and she said elizabeth i think you
should go to therapy and get help and i
was like helpful but she's like just to
like talk about your childhood and like
how that is affecting you now and i was
like okay i can go do that
like the fourth or fifth session i start
to tell a story and i said that i was
really i felt really like i was in
charge of my sister's like life and that
i had failed her because she was she was
not doing what i thought she should be
doing my therapist said why do you feel
responsible for your sister and i said
well my parents always told me it was my
job to make sure that she obeyed the
rules and then when my sister refused to
like hang out with me and like ran from
the room when i was supposed to be
watching her and i would give up on
watching her
my parents would tie us together via a
rope so that we were always together and
i could always make sure she obeyed so
the therapist when she heard that story
was just
like really shocked and she looked at me
and she said elizabeth that's child
abuse and i was like
my parents said it was fine like they
thought it was fine and she was like no
that's child abuse and she said
you know the religious group your
parents are in is definitely a cult and
i was like really and she said yeah they
like control
what you eat and how the people you see
every day and what you
what you read and everything about your
life that's that's a cult and i was like
oh and it for the first time it
like i realized what had happened was
child abuse and that my parents
religious beliefs were not just
religious beliefs but were actually
harmful cult
ideas
i do see myself as a cult survivor and
it was kind of started as a joke to just
like talk about some funny things my
parents said to me on like a podcast and
then i decided to make a tick tock
instead and it kind of just took off and
i feel like a lot of folks in the us
have gone through trauma that's related
to religion and maybe it's not a cult
but it's very fundamental religion that
abuses people and hurts people and just
by having my story out there and just
sharing that you don't have to let that
abuse define you you can name it you can
tell people that it existed without
covering it up so i just started making
tech talks to like educate people about
that and then it turned into people were
very interested to hear my story but it
will hopefully be healing for other
people to who have gone through that
that you can recover you can move on and
you can also
be a better person
[Music]
whilst everybody was having their
orgies free love sex they would no
longer be permitted to
enjoy the sex for each other they had to
fantasize that they were actually having
sex with jesus
men included